hey everyone hey and welcome back to yet
another episode of watching The Watchmen
this is this isn't a regular series you
know I mean you know we read a lot of
comic books on this show we're used to
arcs we're used to getting issues
regularly following the story we're not
like that unfortunately here we're
fairly inconsistent but you know in a
consistent way I think and here we're
doing Watchmen of course if you're
listening to epic issue 4 of this then
you know you want you aren't new this is
one of my favorite issues as well we're
gonna be going through or we always do
you know the story the narratives
theories are just just an appreciation
of Watchmen by Alan Moore and Dave
Gibbons which is just you know one of
the greatest pieces of fiction ever
created no doubt and one of the joys of
doing this show is not only doing it
Watchmen it's some doing it with a
co-host as well deaf how's it go man
yeah we good thank you
I don't know why you keep ringing me at
once every couple of weeks to talk about
the Watchmen but yeah I really enjoy our
phone calls
yeah yeah it's definitely a weird
we relationship we have but I mean I
swear you just ring me up and go oh hey
do you want to talk about Watchmen it F
issue three you know so you know
everything you know has a meaning and
here we're going deep into the story
deep into dr. Manhattan which is you
know one of my favorite characters but
just before we do you know in terms of
the show itself please comment please
subscribe obviously get in touch with us
watching the Watchmen podcast I think is
their email can't quite remember it but
it's on the phone they'll get in touch
with us there and all that sort stuff
but um I mean death so I mean you know
news in sort of Watchmen world there was
like a sequel that came out comic wise
is that right yes so this week the
graphic novel the flash slash right
that's been released as a collection and
it's basically it's sort of a sequel to
flashpoint more than it is Watchmen I
think mmm
and basically weapons is spoiler alert
reverse-flash shows up to beat the crap
out of a Batman in the Batcave and then
he goes to another dimension he comes
back the lads on fire with the blue mist
or whatever is you know the doctor man
harmless and then Batman and the flash
travel to see what happened and they go
back to the flashpoint universe and
where Batman meets Thomas Wayne who is
his dad him was Batman in the flashpoint
universe anyway it's it's a bit of a
time travel story it's not amazing but
it's alright it's kind of one the this
bad thing is like flashpoint ended on um
Batman its dad giving him a letter like
through to give given a letter to a
flash who when the flash returned at the
normal world it give it a Bruce right I
know I butcher in this pot here so
Graham but in the same way that the
ruined Watchmen they were also ruined
flashpoint because they're they've sent
Batman back to me as dad so it was a
it's a nice little doubleheader that
they've managed to do there they've
killed two birds with one stone they're
ruined two things well done DC i I need
to I need to check it out IG but I just
can't
it's like have you read flashpoint I
know I'm aware that like Kevin Smith is
a fan of it that's all I really know
read flashpoint ok sequel of that
basically what happens is flash runs
back in time he stops his mother from
being murdered but with all time-travel
things you know it messes up the the
present and a couple of things get
changed like Superman gets captured by
the government instead of him landing on
a farm in Kansas and Bruce gets shot
instead of his parents and his mum
becomes the Joker his dad becomes Batman
and it's just a couple things like that
and it's it's sort of about flash
and sort of setting things back to how
they were
mmm-hmm there's sort of Alan Moore s
skin it's kind of imaginings there yeah
the the Joker's the mom like that is
daytime wait what yeah makes sense in
the story yeah basically she covers
Bruce and just like sobbing and then she
starts like laughing you know the one
where this song you know when women are
lobbing in the start laughing and then
she turns around and Bruce's Bloods like
the way she's been holding Bruce Lam
it's Bloods actually like covered her
mouth in a smile I'm like sort of smile
so it's so sort of goes from there clam
but basically was saying that the
tragedy sent Bruce's mother as mental
and his father become Batman became
Batman you know as you do Jesus Jesus
and I mean in brief a watchman news
Damon Lindelof is doing like a TV show
now watch me yeah so he's obviously been
checking out the podcast and he saw oh
this would be quite good to UM you know
adapter TV I've already ruined my TV
career with lost Wow just take a comic
and just turn that into a TV show it's
already written it's already filmed
they'll just do that will just do it
yeah yeah yeah I want to see it done
because I'm a huge fan of the fade-out
or than if anyone's read The Fader Ed
Brubaker it's kind of like a nineteen
forties the Hollywood and laughing
anyway honestly everyone needs to read
that that is true I did yeah are you
getting money from Ed Brubaker and Shaun
Phillips this time and this right wise a
great dude
but but yeah the point trying to make it
like you know that the stories so
tightly done as we Watchmen as well that
kind of makes sense as like a sort of
six-part series like if it's just a
fateful adaption of all of these issues
it's gonna be interesting
East yeah I mean it probably won't be
fit be good for newcomers won't it
yeah not gonna be amazing for anyone
who's read the comic and seen the movie
I was busy be ready yeah and played the
board game yeah and and downloaded the
iPhone game on the App Store that was
pre available another funny thing DC
also they've done a hat-trick of ruin in
Watchmen this week and the released the
story called the Doomsday Clock hmm in
which the I don't know I've read it but
basically I watched a video where Jeff
Jones went panel by panel explaining it
let me thought it was really clever
because you know how the first issue a
watchman starts out zoomed in on the
badge and then kind of pulls out
basically the comic starts on a just
someone holding up a picket saying with
the end is near am and it pulls out
slowly and it's like so you see in
Watchmen I think it's giving you a God's
eye view because dr. Manhattan is a card
mmm
so it starts to denna pulls out your
action looking at it from a God's eye
view so I've tried to do that and he was
talking about how he had all these like
hidden meanings and stuff and it doesn't
look like he's got any any meanings in
it
Jeff Jones is a really good writer don't
want to slag the light off but he's
ruined everything but from the ones he
loved the first five pages and basically
um there was a newspaper that had
revealed that Ozymandias had you know
done this horrendous thing and covered
it up with a lie and it was people
marching on the right building and I
think I don't know for definite but I
think Ozymandias kills himself at the
end of the fifth page mm-hmm or that
well they went in a room basically the
the picketers and is it a mob and to
mock them when in the room or any loads
of x-rays up and there was basically an
x-ray that insinuating that human dies
had a brain tumor right yeah just
glad to finally admit all hmm yeah as
you say we're you know we're looking at
alum or the classic obviously this run
and this issue as well watchmaker which
at which I guess we should get into
issue for obviously check out all the
previous episodes where we sort of
recaps everything and gone in deep if
you wanna know if you wanna chatter
stuff out but I don't know about you
deaf but for me there's probably my
favorite covers so far of the series
that the photograph on Mars with the
footprints yeah it's pretty good it's
like little footprint little photograph
touching moment it's it's not clear when
you first watch it could be a beach for
when you first read it but I mean
obviously you learn these on Mars quite
quickly and there's that yet there's an
odd existential dread about it that I
love the sort of this old it's a
black-and-white photo it's clearly like
the 50s like the popcorn and there's a
balloon going away from where it's like
burnt or something like that it's kind
of it's in full of incredible detail so
you're on that level you're sort of like
okay there's this photo and then you
sort of okay there's a photo on Mars and
then you then footprints then like you
know so there's someone here with the
photo yeah now that's quick over the the
ladder looks quite worried in it
yes I been caught cheating on his wife
yeah direct Jon Osterman he looks kind
of deranged there yeah this woman anyway
yeah and it's just it's just yeah I'm
the attention to Devas sort of the
biodome that you see in the background
there which is kind of you know that
we've said before like this Watchmen
world is kind of slightly different from
yeah from our sort of thing and um and
what crap is right that the bad thing
about these days is you couldn't just
replicate images when you were drawing
and so Dave Gibbons literally would I
draw this photo a thousand times eggs
with that balloon you can even say that
balloon floating above the hen the
ticket row and that
you know this watchman's so good at
giving us that sort of inner stream of
consciousness of the characters and you
know dr. Manhattan his philosophy is
teased at but I think in this issue you
really sort of learn who he is the the
sense even in those those two opening
panels where he's kind of he's
predicting into the future what he's
actually gonna be doing it's really
really weird yeah it's crazy it sort of
gives you straightaway the perspective
that abused time from mmm and everything
is preordained similar to the this
turning of cogs and a watch everything
has to happen in a certain way in order
for the cogs to turn and that there's a
repetition of falling in this issue as
well but it's just nice for him to have
like this somber moment where he's just
away from everything and he's just
looking back on his life both physically
through the photograph and also
spiritually through time mmm and the
opening the photograph in my hand of a
man and a woman they are at an amusement
park in 1959 so I mean we learn again
that this is him but there is this kind
of just this detached nature where that
was him but it was him in the past you
know I mean he's completely you know
he's not this man anymore
well there's a scientific theory that
because the way that cells change within
a human body we're not even the same
people that we were 10 years ago like
made of completely different things um
but yeah so he's sort of looking back I
mean even as a person I feel like
completely different to the way I was 10
years ago I mean if I didn't have my
memories I don't think I'd be you know
I'll have all those horrific memories of
the men on the site also I wouldn't have
liked the knowledge that I'm I've had a
pass lights
mmm which is what John's looking at this
photo
imagining probably he might not be you
might be thinking about
I wonder what Snoop Dogg's next
Instagram post his grandpa he already
knows
yeah it is you know any you know the
whole sequence it's you know the tight
boxes the Gibbons does the compactness
of to eat it for out Watchmen really but
yeah I think you know in in in issues
you we the stars gleaming behind him as
well and just the the kind of almost
ridiculousness of this blue man on Mars
but it's very poetic yeah and it's a
shame that he throws the photograph away
because he could do a great hashtag
throwbackthursday with that yeah just as
he's waiting for Snoop Dogg but I
digress um yes it's really nice and he
drops the phone on he walks away from it
because he saw at this moment that he
accepts that he's done with humanity
he's on Mars and this is the last thing
that was sort of holding him to human
self like he says in the last issue that
it's the last four it's the only
photograph that people have um might
even be this issue at his funeral and
but this is sort of the thing that's
holding him to humanity and it's really
symbolic that he drops it yeah it just
walks away from it yeah yeah yeah and
all we ever see of stars are their old
photographs it's kind of almost you know
year nine GTC poetry but it's quite I
don't know it's quite affecting any kind
of yeah is that an illusion for him so
he's saying that okay so the the the
light from these stars is coming you
know through a sort of vortex whatever
it's paused but can he not see the light
already I don't you know what I mean how
I'm limiting is he her II don't know but
maybe sort of showing that you know the
lights coming through and you get a
glimpse of something but there's nothing
you can do about it and then the same
way that he's looking at a photograph of
something that's happened he's looked at
the Stars something that's happened and
his entire life must be something that's
already happened to him and because he's
just unable to control all the influence
in any way in the same way that you can
see the stars but you can't influence
them I'm trying to get a point across
here where I'm finding it really
difficult so basically everything set in
stone but or we can and all we can do is
look at it
in the same way that all you can do is
look at this for
Graff all he can do is look at the Stars
he's gonna have no impact on it
he means nothing everyone means nothing
life's pointless and when you die
there's nothing and the the second page
which has the title on it is incredibly
framed so you have sort of if you were
to mention like a five on a dice like
you have those sort of the dr. Manhattan
is zooming out from him and you realize
in this sort of dark expanse of space
but the other three are hands and
there's two yeah
there's two doctor and hat hands blue
hands four in the photo and there's one
John Austin would hand like picking up a
small cog of overwatch like it's
delicious imagery isn't it oh it's
really good and just the repetition of
the falling throughout the session we
get the repetition of the photograph
falling mixed in with the cogs yeah you
don't need to throw the cogs man yeah
and it sort of ties in ooh the the bombs
that are gonna fall hmm eventually so
yeah it's a nice you know it's a nice
repetition thematically throughout it
he's dating some it mental yeah the ex
paging reads it about her Ashima and
Einstein saying that times relative and
he just decides you know what sod this I
know I've been making a living off
fixing watches but I'm just gonna throw
them over the balcony
mmm I love professor Einstein says that
time differs from place to place can you
imagine if time is not true what purpose
have watchmakers watchmakers Hine and he
says ah here as well so it's kind of
this nice and Nationality to and him
standing on this very sort of like I
don't know working-class bird like a sky
porch
yeah and it's mirrored by dr. Manhattan
our palace amazing atmosphere of Mars
where meteorites hail down and the
rarefied it's just really well put
together it is any you know we follow
John he's kind of origin here which is
what these early issues do so well
and we meet him in a kind of because at
this point superheroes kind of
exist I guess with the Minutemen to a
certain extent but you know in a very
superhero type place isn't it this
origin it's like man becoming beasts
it's got to be like a science facility
yeah it sort of reminds me of the
Incredible Hulk
TV show right yeah well it's you know
he's doing a science experiment and then
he gets locked in it by accident he gets
blasted with gamma rays and he becomes
this amazing superhero man gonna save
the world kids make sure you check out
next episode there's some crazy
transitions like in the face of me I'm
getting in the in the start of the fifth
page when you see him looking in as a
freshman essentially a beers being
poured and then he just cuts to him and
the stars outside and he's like this
kind of alien man like I incredible to
me yeah and it I suppose it sort of is
how dr. Manhattan would truest to time
you I don't think you would exist in the
moment every single moment what would
happen is he goes somewhere and that
would trigger a memory that would take
him back to to the point in his life and
which might be why it's mirrored so
often for instance when he's walking in
the bar in 19th in the 1950s he's then
walking in the bar on in the 1985 and
maybe these things are just triggering
memories for him and he's able to go
back and relive them as if they're
happening now because his his beings
perfect so his memory doesn't have any
faults in it and maybe he's just you
know he's dude you're walking along then
you remember it's been like a flashback
from Family Guy mm-hm
they let's say something and then it
flashes to a joke but we've said maybe
maybe dr. Manhattan is the prototype for
Family Guy yeah yeah but potentially and
you see John as well as already kind of
superhuman even before we became [ __ ]
like she says like oh you're pretty
young for a research scientist and he's
a high achiever to a certain extent so
yeah I guess like a Bruce Banner as well
again I guess someone why'd you get it
and again
you know the flitting through time she
buys me a beer the first time a woman
has ever done this for me as she passes
me the cold perspiring glass our fingers
such Alan Moore is you know terrific
rides were just capturing these kind of
intense hush moments and then him just
go into a you know making love and she's
Taylor Stanga three years later and the
photograph lies on my feet like in a
repetition as you say the kind of the
tic-tock nature of it it's just very
powerful yeah and it's all present tense
as well and so it's Moyes in the moment
it's not like we went to it's like we
are at yeah yeah she says me not she
passed and it's just keeping you in the
moment through and I find it really
engaging to read because of that to be
honest you're constantly in the moment
so no matter what's happening on you
know there's a sense of urgency to it
because it's happening right now
throughout this entire issue and it's
it's sort of it's great how even when he
walks into the bar as a normal man Esau
gets a sense of deja vu which you would
because himself in the future is
troubling back and being in that
consciousness Marissa
I've sort of always kind of had this
view of time myself and where it's all
cyclical but humans are hard-wired to be
with and it's linearity but you know
everything that will happen has to
happen because everything that has
happened has happened in order to set up
it so that time arrives that it's
eventually and it's sort of you know
tiny issue it's sort of like a clock
without a craftsman and where everything
is just constantly spinning and and you
don't really you know it's all in motion
and like if you everything in your life
that has happened has built up to you
being right here right now recording
this crappy podcast so there will be
some being some point in your life where
you have to do this thing where you have
to watch battle raps because battle
rapidly you don't you doing a podcast
which we lead on you doing the crabby
watching the water odd and it's sort of
everything tie
everything and has to happen the way it
has to happen because of its eventually
if that's that I've been on a bit deep
run there but yeah I do kind of relate
to this I know that Alan were all sort
of things the same way because if you
read from Hell there's a lot of moments
in that where Jack the Ripper sees the
future and there's one point where he is
just walking past an alleyway in London
and he looks in a window and there's
just a man there sitting from the 70s um
like the 1970s watching TV and the both
just kind of look at each other like
shocked I think there's a point as well
where he walks into where Jack walks
into a modern-day Trafalgar Square
hmm I mean it's really good that Moore's
sort of established this character that
embodies his beliefs almost and I really
relate to it to be honest yeah no it's
just effortless storytelling which is
what more can do he's so concise he's
got such quality like um one of the
things I want to turn any any readers
onto and I want to pick this up but that
have you ever heard of future shocks
hello sir hey hey you can hear me man
yeah yeah have you ever heard of future
shocks in common no it's like it was
sowing for 2000ad and it was like their
early writers like Neil Gaiman came up
for and loads of other guys as well and
he's just like one page comics and Alan
Moore was apparently got the master of
these and there is actually a collection
you can get on Amazon which I really
need to pick up and they need to sponsor
us as well go for the affiliate link but
you know Alan he just does it so well
and you know on page six at the bottom
we have the lovemaking that we've
mentioned before yeah all these things
that I mentioned before that are coming
back you know even the focus on the
old-style camera and you know then
posing for the photo that we see on the
cover and we see kind of like a faded
version of it first and the actual
reality it's really rich yeah and I
actually do have in my notes that this
entire issue just works as a standalone
story yeah yeah but yeah I mean you
could just pick it up in it works
brilliantly in history and there's
actually a DC of released a comic called
love is love which is all just one page
stories and something around the Florida
shooting of a gay club and it's all sort
of discussing people's love Ives and how
and the stories about people coming out
and you know people getting murdered at
the nightclub and it's it's a really
good really really good read if you like
these sort of one one-shot things that's
cool that's cool I definitely will check
out but uh yeah you know we have
inevitably the transformation for dr.
Manhattan you know he goes through into
the fit class that we saw preview prior
and it's the sense of sheer horror that
I think give Gibbons captures you look
at these faces that are seen you know
through the radiate glass like they are
just like the pair despair oh yeah
Colette's you sometimes absolutely I
think the green it's a it's sort of
almost like a 1940's horror movie green
if that makes sense like sauce slime and
it's really you know I'm a website
designer and trade and we've been solved
the new company I work for at the moment
we've been discussing a lot of colors
and what colors mean on a website so red
off obviously means allure green sort of
means to go and and the use of color is
a very important thing to give you
emotion and so the fact that they're
horrified and they're in dark green you
know it's a very emotional thing of just
sheer terror that sort of harkens back
to those old horror movie posters and
then the entire color gets stripped away
when dr. Manhattan gets sort of
obliterated yeah the infuse of color and
just the sort of I agree the sort of
quite nice sepia sort of way it delivers
itself as well and then into a kind of
ejaculation pause of emotion visually on
page eight the explosion of John the
incineration of him back dropped him
holding the watch as well is such a a
beautiful thing but I love his
transformation I especially love are the
following pages a sort of brain and
synapse yawn yeah and what like it has
to be put in every single hero origin is
that not normal this couldn't happen to
a normal person and they could get
through it like what's great about this
is you learn that John used to be a
watchmaker so if if Janie had his
stumbled in there and had it got
obliterated she wouldn't be able to get
the past hours of dr. Manhattan because
she wouldn't be able to reveal herself
and he spied police in the same way that
John had when he was a watchmaker and so
it's good that they sort of put this
rule in very subtly that you know Russia
couldn't just copy and make their own
dr. Manhattan ma'am it's same with i
captain america and the the super CEO of
the Super Soldier Serum which got
destroyed after after he got made and
there needs to be a certain rules that
stop normal people from becoming these
heroes so there's not just millions of
them walking around so it's it's nice
that they certainly put this in all that
looks a bit like an ink blot test as
well yeah sort of ties into Rorschach
and I think when Rorschach gets killed
later
spoiler alert by the way they they sort
of harken back to this hmm
- do they do they do it you have to do
it so and when ya when dr. Manhattan
goes to stop Ozymandias and human dies
obliterates them it talking's back to
this heavily it's it's pretty much the
same image but it's got Bubastis in it
oh yeah you know of course yeah and you
do we see him as a circulatory system
and just the sort of the scalar and the
skin building ever here are the cogs as
well on on page 10 we have my hand the
birth of him quite quite obvious over
toe
sort of you know God like here isn't
there yeah everyone's just shittin
themselves and then he sort of appears
flowing above them arm stretched out
completely nude so harkens back to like
Michelangelo's Statue you know it's as a
David is that you yeah yeah so yeah it's
it's he's perfectly built anatomically
and you know he's he's floating above
these people has cut the reef line
everywhere
he's just how no one knows what I do
with a lad
it's God he's here yeah check out my
dick yeah I and you know that I really
like the panel of Jamie actually sort of
the wind blowing her back and she saw
his sheep in sheepishly asking you know
she knows she sort of knows instantly
that it is him yeah which is which is
quite intriguing and you know it's it's
great that he debuts God debuts not at a
church or a sort of Oasis amongst
scientists you know anything here
amongst critiques yeah exactly
astounded by as well it's sort of the
second coming is here o scientists what
you been doing slugging off the Bible
I'm here you know I mean the lads here
and he's blue da ba dee da ba die I
think that it's you know issue they
quote a song mmm it be it's a shame that
I'm blue double D
yeah but that wasn't out quote for this
issue they use Einstein actually in this
issue but I think yeah yeah and we see
the early life of John and Jamie which
is obviously brought how can you live
you know with someone like this and
they're celebrating Christmas quite a
superficial thing yeah for him really
but he's still doing yeah I guess yeah
which you know everyone everyone and by
everyone I mean just me on this podcast
say that says that dr. manhattan's
totally detached from humanity and but
just from the fact that he lies to her
it does show that he cares if he didn't
care he wouldn't allow you when he's
talking about how he'll always want her
even though she knows deep down you know
the relationships never gonna work yeah
of course I mean you know it needs a
trial run we see later on that equally
it doesn't I always want you I'll always
want you he says the man who knows
infinity is is playing these lights yeah
it shows he cares I mean it's the old
classic one in it
your wife's pregnant you know you're
gonna yeah as soon as the new cigarette
restart I work you're off but you tell
your wife for you and the kids they even
say the sentence I don't think there is
a God if there is I got him so it's like
you know I don't you know this
questioning beautiful beautiful you know
ideas that he puts out there and again
moving forward dr. Mahan
you know he's co-opted in a certain
sense to be a hero obviously the
ambivalence was there beginning and you
know so much is labored over in the
origin story the logo the look but for
him II purely just sort of just does it
in momentarily yeah it's sort of been
used as a propaganda piece to be honest
I don't think America care about his
feelings at all they're just more
bothered about the the fear that he's
gonna put into Russia and America's
enemies and that that's why they kind of
want to build him as a brand and just
the the wonderful irony that the the
front of the newspaper that he was shown
as a child this kind of evokes what his
moniker is yeah so the Manhattan Project
was basically when scientists created
the atomic bomb and it's clear that you
know the fact that dr. Manhattan's
called dr. Manhattan is what caused
Russia to fear another atomic strike
which is probably why they've stockpiled
so many weapons and it just like
the fact that Alan was thought of the
character's name and how it played like
every character in this book has a name
that sort of plays into their origin and
depth my Rorschach
dr. Manhattan obviously the name
synonymous with atomic war and it's just
really you know he's thinking on another
level here the lad he's a bit like
myself I was talking about time before
just the power that we see and and
beautifully we're seeing it for a TV
screen you know we're not kind of just
shown him in the moment here we're sort
of reliving a highlights real he's
assembling a gun I level here's him you
know nuking a tank like you know they
sort of it's ajik aureus display and I
love how they interview captain
metropolis have just looks very bemused
yeah I don't know if dr. Manhattan
actually has like proper superpowers and
what I think it is right because they
were talking about that the science
chamber was used to see if things had an
intrinsic field and if they did if if it
was possible to separate it obviously
what happened to John was he got removed
from his intrinsic field which caused
him a disintegrate in disperse what I
think dr. Manhattan's actual power is is
that he can just move things
intrinsically so when he's dismantling
objects all he's doing it's displacing
their intrinsic field it's never really
said in the book
I've not googled it or anything so if
there is something where Alan Moore says
whoever says intrinsic fields is what
dr. Manhattan's power is is a [ __ ] I
don't know that it's just dunno
the lad was test and foreign to trinsic
fields you know what I'm saying mama
mmm-hmm no I I dig you homie I take you
and yeah dr. Manhattan he said not to
spoke to the press
so we move therefore you know very
elegantly in a sense of an interview
sort of a program to talk into the
costume heroes remaining from the 1940s
masked hero fad that they mentioned here
and he says you know he very very
pleased you know but clearly is caught
in this bolo say we see Silk Spectre
Sally Jupiter underneath in brackets
we've seen you know we kind of go back
and just like him saying at the end I
feel as if I've been here that all all
all the time I guess your sense of that
would overpower any you know non
knowledge you had I guess yeah
definitely
and just I love the way that he's going
around murdering people in one panel and
he's just like the morality of my
activities
the guy doesn't care it's just going
through the motions to sort of please
America I mean it clearly knows John F
Kennedy is gonna get shot he doesn't and
he's just what I love about worries he's
got a very dry sense of humor and so
when dr. Manhattan's talking to the
original Nite Owl at the awards ceremony
the original night owl says well you
know I'm gonna go retire and just fix
cars mmm doctor man huh yeah we hit
because you've made me redundant like
night owl just feels completely
pointless now that he's met dr.
Manhattan so he thinks he said even says
it'll be a while before even you affect
General Motors and then go ahead and
doctor man that goes well the new
electric cars should be even simpler and
you just saw the [ __ ] once again makes
them completely yeah yeah
unintentionally and it's just yeah it's
just a great dry sense of humor that
that Moore has he's endowed this
completely just stoic character with
this you know this great sense of humor
that's completely unintentional and you
see the division in these areas him
saying you know Hollis saying Eddie you
know all I've got to offer is a good
left hook which means which means
fuck-all it like stasis space
combat and I like the earlier ones as
well just where you see him those free
panels you know you see him at the Red
Cross event Ozzie froze they get to
mention throughout but it's never you
know it's always in there but you see
you easy Mothman there you see Captain
ridiculous you see this right big lot of
big things happen there mmm definitely
and you get to see stuff but now blowing
up someone's head yeah lovely the
ladders okay you've got what's that lad
called with the pointy ears
Oh Moloch Moloch you've got Moloch their
point yeah I should have read Moloch in
the Box there before saying what's that
loud with few true fans you got your
Moloch on lock man you got more JFK and
you see Jackie and it's just like I
don't know about you death but like
American history there's something quite
romantic about JFK I guess yeah and it's
weird how like often he gets used in
fiction as well lacy you know I mean if
they did something like where I'm trying
to think of a murder victim without
being really offensive but that in
itself shows that what happened in JFK's
just become completely detached from the
reality of it
this guy got assassinated on live TV and
it's used in fiction all the time
because no one cares um
think of someone famous who got murdered
recently definitely yeah why not yeah
well imagine that was on TV all the time
how does yeah you know that would be no
you're right and he gets palmful well I
think the Twin Towers a start sort of
starting to become a bit like that
mm-hmm where people are sort of detached
from it in fictional eyes are like if
you watch the start of Batman V Superman
like that is 9/11 right like the fact
that it's got superheros flying around
doesn't really made that much of a
difference and it is very strange
JFK's assassination has become just like
just used to the plot point for a lot of
things mm-hmm
always man I mean died young he's just
idealized you know anything from x-men
first class to you know yeah [ __ ] you
know Watchmen like it's great of course
it's great to see man we see in the yeah
you know he died and then moving forward
from this as well and the first meeting
of these people it's not quite clear why
necessarily dr. Manhattan squeeze would
be there but she's there anyway and oh
yeah why not just like it's not Wi-Fi
back then so he's you know just
something to do but what was the you
know this meeting is well very important
wasn't it for kind of what what what
there's all formation of the league yeah
definitely yeah it's it's great that
they keep holding him back to these
moments like if you wrote down on paper
how many different things happen in
Watchmen there's not that many
especially for a book this length but
it's shown you from everyone's
perspective so you get more of an
in-depth understanding of the situation
that they're in and in doing so you also
see it from their perspective so you get
an in-depth understanding of the
character as well and it's a really
great way it just constantly play up
these scenarios and because it offers
something new every single time you look
at it as well one of the one of the
great things I think about inception is
every time I watch that film I see
something different and it's very hard
to do especially when you used to seen
the same scenarios over and over in the
fact that mujer has these same scenarios
scenarios whatever but there's something
different happening them happening in
them every time and not only paints
makes you understand what is going on a
little bit more but it also makes you
understand the character mmm ya know
certainly I mean here we see night owl
leaving as well in his is is kind of you
know our machine and just a you I agree
you snatches of conversations have said
you see the whole thing in another issue
we see dr. manhattan's hands you know on
silk spectres face there and you know
which we've seen before we see them
kissing as well
the smaller gentler kiss upon the other
one like a signature again it's just you
know very florid but very nice yeah and
it just it just again the man's kind of
isolation from this moment as well
there's just there's a lot of sort of
romantic intrigue I suppose which is
kind of granted and you think the way
that sort of dr. Manhattan's detached
from JFK's assassination is sort of a
comment on how the world's become
detached from that assassination but
like you know John like John Lennon got
assassinated imagine if that became like
a plot point in loads of different films
oh yeah Yoko Ono would have to watch
some of them you know I mean when when
she's seen her husband getting gunned
down like Jackie Kennedy she she's had
basically probably one of the most
horrific moments of our life probably
the most horrific moments sitting in a
car watching her husband get shot and it
sort of gets fictionalized so much in
you so much as a cool moment and like TV
shows and films that it's sort of we
became detached from it in the same way
that dr. Manhattan has and maybe this
high perspective that he has is sort of
the perspective that the media paints in
things or maybe I'm just talking out me
ass
yeah yeah as you as you were saying that
and I was this thing I just watched the
JFK assassination Gavin scene in a wall
[ __ ] man it's gruesome yeah it's her in
this like if you watch like I think it's
called 2211 63 that entire TV show is
set around James Franco going back and
stopping JFK from getting assassinated
mmm how is that I haven't think you've
seen oh it's absolutely brilliant I
cried at the end of it really I can
really good I'll shake to have it um and
yeah yeah you know a big big big fan and
we see him speaking to Nixon we see him
eating comedian more importantly happier
times a comedian with with his lady yes
she's smiling that you get to say but
you know everyone's just have no laughs
yeah yeah well there's a few I mean if
you look in the back the guy at the door
in that scene looks like the most
typical Vietnam guy ever yeah he's got
like the Halloween costume that people
had you know when people go to a party
in LA I wanna go as a Vietnam soldier
you know the part yeah yeah you know
have the toga party on a Sunday and have
the Vietnam soldier partying a Monday
he's got a costume from that well and
then we see comedian again with his
flamethrower you know a freeze-frame
essentially a zoom in and yeah the kind
of something very tragic and broken but
also very clever that the fact that dr.
Manhattan kind of he understands no one
but comedian his motives he gets ya
where he's got God's eye perspective on
things as Jeff Jones would say he saw
above everything in above all the
morality and the understanding like I'm
gonna get political now but there
there's so much hypocrisy within the
government like it the government will
say it's wrong to murder someone yet
they'll happily sanction people like
soldiers to go abroad and murder people
either the thousands and yet if Jimmy
from down the road you know he's a bit
of a funny lad he likes to stare out the
window watching the women pass if he
goes out one night in murder as a woman
all hell's gonna [ __ ] break loose yet
the and the government's gonna be like
you can't do that you can't do that
Jimmy we've had a word with you and but
on the same day that the government will
send people out to murder people
so they're saying murder is wrong and
one in one way but doing it themselves
and we do live in a very hypocritical
society I
just think Mona's wrong all round yet so
don't I haven't been hanging around with
Jimmy or anything and but like the the
Columbine shooting I remember there was
a statistic on that Bill Clinton the
morning of the Columbine shooting was
like oh these guys have done a terrible
thing you should never kill people the
same day he was sending jets to the
Middle East to bomb countries and kill
people it's just completely hypocritical
tone I'm bloody sick of it so understand
that he sees it all is a big joke and
dr. Manhattan you can see that you know
he knows the same thing so yeah it's
it's just I think the comedian dr.
Manhattan probably have the most in
common however everyone in this comic
certainly and again we get a full
profile dr. Manhattan him destroying
things of a finger this is the first
time we've really seen him ant-man
himself up you know grow to a huge size
of course he can do this he could become
a planet if he wanted to
goddamnit like you know that would be
yeah I don't know maybe if you could do
that but he could do a lot of things and
to the point where people are
surrendering to him like it's like a
genuine God yeah he's a deity isn't
really and you know his legend the fact
that he's just a power has no limit that
they're just scared and you know a lot
of religion comes from fear what's while
we get to see inside Aziz sort of snow
palace as well it's just a credit to the
creative work of these guys and all the
locations are very unique and
interesting yeah and it's really well
plant now like the the snow base pops up
over and over and it's sort of a
callback to Carmack and it's just more
as thought about every single aspect of
these characters like where would the
hang out why would they do that what in
their posture make them build how would
the interior look and it's all sort of
ties in to paint a picture of how the
character is like if someone lives in
there is a superhero yet they live in a
dark dank apartment and it's all
speaks volumes about that personal life
and in the same way that Ozymandias has
this huge palace it speaks volumes
today's ego as well yeah in Italian just
seeing inside it as well these fresh
flowers and these kind of Egyptian
columns and the art and yeah it's
delightful as all the T's of the dome
and they're speaking about the future
and you know again dr. Manhattan kind of
playing a houseguest to a certain extent
still working within these some
sociological confines
we then see him levitating with sand in
his hand like kind of elevating I've
always loved in this section when you
see him sort of trying to fight crime
which obviously was never really that
hot on that guy's shouting oh yeah and
what if we don't you big blue fruit yeah
he drops a podcast he says I don't like
the word beat says my son was a police
officer you [ __ ] right and that's all
you've got a great like EF a dialog in
capturing what people are saying mmm
yeah no Italian the mob the framed in
red the faces beautiful lorry just kind
of doing what she can do in the moment
but Dodds when I'm floating above detach
him transporting everyone I mean it's
not different to the whole television
debacle right yeah well it's all how it
deals with all of his problems by the
looks of a I mean I don't want to slug
the light off but you did just run away
to Mars mm and now we saw just he caught
he doesn't deal with problems well he
just sort of shuffles them out the way
to one side the lads a bit of a [ __ ]
now yeah
the senator keen is mentioned we get the
solve almost Days of Future past like
poster of their faces like crossed out
and stuff yeah the you know the the the
the sand playing for the hands over the
picture of comedian coming off the plane
which are very sort of classic Americana
like JFK that have been warped slightly
I don't know who I seen as I step off
the plane and start walking down the
steps and waving at people I mean it's a
very weird iconography but it's present
here it symbolizes America heavily and
the fact that the comedians also do a
sort of shows that you know he is
America mm-hmm yeah definitely I mean in
freeing these people as well
I believe it yeah it says it was from
the Iranian hostage situation which is
IB he's wearing his [ __ ] mask at this
portion as well yeah costume you know
changes we learn about night owl
retiring obviously Rorschach is still
active we heard this mention before
didn't we've been the never staple to
the chest yeah brilliant
it's just completely defiant he's not
compromising the lad still out there
yes console' oh he's not doing it as a
job it's not something that you can stop
doing it's just this is Rorschach they'd
be like telling the fish to stop
swimming you know I mean the lad
this is his existence and it's not gonna
stop because some government tell them
not to I just can't believe that on
these pages these 24 and 25 you know
right towards the end and the sort of
confluence of timelines is really like
meshing and pre edge every panel is
leaping decades and back and forth and
and realities and like it's dizzying
yeah and there's a certain tempo to this
issue as well mmm that slowly starts to
build up it's it's almost like have you
seen Dunkirk
I haven't actually known so throughout
Dunkirk and even in the soundtrack
that's sort of it I think it might be
present in interstellar as well there's
sort of a tick tick tick tick and a lot
of Christopher Nolan's work feels like a
clock almost um and you sort of have
throughout this issue a tick tick and
it's as it's getting towards this
buildup that the tick gets faster and
faster as the the pages come closer and
closer together and then when dr.
Manhattan when it cuts to him out Mars
you just have vast expanses without the
tick so if you imagine every single
analyzer the stroke of a watch it really
starts to speed up at this point and as
it's speeding up it's also jumping
decades and decades and thematically
it's such a well structured issue man
you really ain't gross in the fact that
it's you know this story is about a
watchmaker and it operates almost like
time it's great yeah yeah it is it is
incredible from seeing him deep blue you
know getting ready for the TV lorry
leaving the special talent quarters the
funeral then being told of comedians
death you know that the photo yet again
it plays that so well and then we sort
of end on a very you know kind of
watchman I guess you could argue to a
certain extent it's been quite grounded
so far but we've docked mahan of calls
you have to kind of go out these
boundaries him creating this kind of
giant crystal world from from Mars how
do you read this um I don't know it
seems to be a giant watch to be on end
it's got like hands on it but I've never
been I've never really understood it to
be on earth either their thing with
these issues I'm not actually researched
any Watchmen write this read it and sort
of said in the podcast what I think it
mean isn't never know if I'm right or
wrong with it
but when it comes to moments like this
and I've got no idea what what's going
on I sound like even more of an idiot
than I normally do am so yeah well
absolutely no idea yeah he just I guess
you know he is just kind of playing
again creator with what he can do but
yeah I don't know actually the meaning
behind him training this giant fortress
but you know besides some allegorical
one like you know narrative Lee wise I
don't think there's anything obviously
this is kind of his domain to a certain
extent where exists again we get that a
great shot of the black cogs against the
white sari against the yellow now which
kind of gives it you know a bit of a
difference there is it's kind of growing
up and just to end with him yet again
watching some ink falling and the meteor
shower as well which just just kind of
places you in this really
extraterrestrial world yeah it's nice
how sort of says the world grows around
me
am i shaping it or do its predetermined
contours guide my hand when he talks
about how everything in his life's build
up to this moment like if the the fat
man hadn't crushed the watch it if it if
I hadn't left it in the test chamber and
I to blame then or the fat man or my
father for choosing my career which you
wanted which one of us is responsible
who makes the world it's very poetic and
it's sort of it's sort of a way for him
from everything now realizing that you
know it's a clock without a craftsman
perhaps the world is not made perhaps
nothing has made perhaps it simply is
has been and will always be there and
it's just sort of it's great to see how
we've used the world yeah yeah entirely
and we close with you know not a lyric
and fortunately not when not on blue
either album dr. Manhattan would know if
you could see the future that's yeah
yeah I think he'd have that maybe that's
why he turned himself blue yeah yeah
yeah cuz I guess he would have predicted
it at that time he wouldn't know yeah
woody came say yeah you know that makes
sense that makes sense and Albert
Einstein saying that you know basically
regrets splitting the atom changing
everything releasing this power if only
I had known I should have become a
watchmaker yeah great
brilliant no it's such a mix Oh such a
genius you know especially when I is
left DC and then Jeff Jones comes along
and he's like well so what God's eye
view you know what I mean as a yeah mate
I've read Watchmen so what you're
talking about now is absolute nonsense
in comparison at that get off ya know
they're angry I mean yeah Alan Moore for
me he's one of my heroes like in terms
of writing and like like creating it
could just be making up this quote yes
every quote seems to be like absolutely
perfect
his research game is just you know you
know out of this world and I mean we
ain't weary in a net as well yeah yeah
yeah
I mean he's wildly intelligent and the
final though the sort of the dr.
Manhattan super powers and the super
powers which is you know very witty in
seeing him and does vitruvian man with
the flag and you know it's a brilliant
cover actually he's kind of like a
classic so cover but sort of what he
says in there isn't much said in this
really like you just sort of reiterates
the point how deadly dr. Manhattan is
and how important he is but it's not
like a sort of Hollis Mason under the
hood where you learn a lot more really
that it's probably the weakest out of
the the back issues but like the story
segments yeah yeah you've got like the
news report as talking about how he was
misquoted and he didn't say that God he
didn't say that the Superman exists and
he's American he actually said was God
exists and he's American which look yeah
I've read the book he doesn't say that
he says the first thing that he says he
didn't say so that's a load of crap
yeah like this that much and it's sort
of talking about how just basically how
contradictory the world it is like how
there's children starving and whilst
boots that cost thousands of dollars
walk on the moon and we prepare for war
yet a rate piece and it's just talking
about how contradictory humans are in
general the and it's just like it's it's
sort of the perspective of a news report
on that will we get to see for two
panels or something and so I'm not that
invested in this story no no no I I
concur mind you it's not but the issue
so I mean it's I think it's as you
before like you know it's one of my
favorite bits of graphic novel ever like
yeah I I think just from a storytelling
perspective I think it's absolutely
pitch perfect a fascinating character
you know treated correctly with the
whole watch stuff running through and
yeah it's just I mean any any closing
fors in this issue death it's a home run
isn't it like
brilliant I often find this with TV
shows where you know the first episodes
okay
the second episodes okay the third
episodes okay and it's normally about
the fourth that the the writers sort of
save all the best ideas for and I mean
it happened with jessica jones thinking
about that most recently and a lot of TV
shows do this whether the fourth
episodes something either really just
hit home and everything falls into place
and it gets a new it's tried and I think
this is where the book really elevates
and you can sort of begin to understand
all the ideas that Moore has within it
it would be weird to kind of go back in
time and sort of read this issue by
issue month by month because I don't
know how people would have you know
picked up on the first three issues yeah
I know for a fact that I definitely
would've missed all of the stuff and
yeah but I think this would have been
the issue that sort of began to get into
how everything worked within the clock
and within the story like you do realize
that everything is a clock and it's also
preordained and everything's slowly
fitting together and building towards
something and it's just an absolute
masterpiece
dr. Manhattan is from this issue alone
one of the most fascinating characters
in comics hmm yeah I can't I mean him
and him an Aquaman they're taught to
yeah I love how men in the Justice
League trailers mannion cuz I've just
started watching Rick and Morty as well
alright and there's a postman in that
who just called mommy so it's good that
DC's taking it seriously and I mean this
is a few for you know we refer to the
way fruit the so much detail the yeah
these are incredible incredible pieces
of work and it's it's been a joy man I
guess um your website how do people get
at that yeah so if you go to definition
Cora
that's my website I'm a bit ill at the
moment a voice is a bit croaky so you
know - as a favour visit the website
i'll cheer is a-- i'm currently
reviewing the justice league new 52 run
which sort of is building towards
forever evil which is where super
villains took off the world and defeated
the Justice League Lex Luthor in the
lads their heart has stopped them so
really good run more so I've just
started reading Death Note mmm and
that's I cannot believe how good that is
I've went oh I've never really I've
heard about death now in the past but
you know I saw it thought was a bit of a
stupid idea but reading it it's
absolutely incredible
it's one of the only books of reviewed
and given a 10 out of 10 and so I
definitely recommend picking that up
awesome that's good man yeah what about
you know I think I might mention this
before but the way I sort of read comics
is more I'll just read like writers that
I like rather than like stuff so Jason
Aaron who's someone like [ __ ] love
southern bastards I'm sure some people
might have where where this from image
it's basically taking this like a
deep-fried noir crime sort of it's
taking like the you know you know these
small towns that love college football
and like they have to win every game
like it's taking that idea but it's
making into like a crime story it's
really [ __ ] good man there's like
there's like it's all about the games
and stuff and like the [ __ ] so the
second are like it spends like six
issues and each issues just with a
character and then the final issue is
like at this game and all the characters
are there and like trying to kill all
this guy it's really good honestly the
writing get any good so yeah check out
seven bastards listeners but obviously
keep listening to us as well yeah you
know obviously me and deaf have done
loads of Barrett resume stuff we'll do
some stuff in the future by obviously
they saw stuff we will come back and do
something non Watchmen I think so man
yeah I think midseason break issue six
will probably probably go off and do
we'll review a different graphic novel
yeah and you know we've been talking
about bits and bobs at work we could do
but I mean exactly you know specify the
project so if this a graphic novel that
you want us to break down make sure you
email that wherever the email is once it
watching The Watchmen and Watchmen calm
kora UK you know better than me - well
tell you what tweet either me or Tom you
can get at me at at definition MC and
you can get Tom at watching the Watchmen
at gmail.com that's it that's it that's
the one I have our resume as well but
yeah um will be on the description as
well if you wanna send us a message get
in touch with us please we wanted some
emails to read out like I do another I
do if you have a podcast and if you got
an email in the first four episodes like
you're slacking boy like I'm like I'm a
little bit ashamed so we'll get one even
if it is me as an acronym we aren't we
all gonna go free but def as always it's
been a treatment Thank You Man yeah
thanks a lot mate make sure your ring is
next month and we'll talk about issue 5
we we will and dear listeners if you
happen to catch that we'll do it sooner
rather than later we realized it's been
kind of a long break yeah but we'll well
you know we'll be doing that with in a
little bit but def as always man thank
you bro take care mummy
[Music]